- So one interesting philosophical point
in quantum mechanics bring up is the,
that you talk about the distinction
between the world as it is and
the world as we observe it.
So, staying at the human
level for a second.
How big is the gap between
what our perception
system allows us to see
and the world as is is
outside our mind's eye,
sort of, not at the
quantum mechanical level
but as just our, these
particular tools we have
which is a few senses and
our cognitive abilities
to process those senses?
- Well, that last phrase,
"Having the cognitive
abilities to process them."
carries a lot, right?
I mean there is our sort
of intuitive understanding
of the world.
You don't need to teach
people about gravity
for them to know that apples
fall from trees, right?
That's something that we
figure out pretty quickly.
Object permanence, things like that.
The three-dimensionality of space,
even if we don't have the
mathematical language to say that,
we kind of know that it's true.
On the other hand, no one opens
their eyes and sees atoms.
Or molecules, or cells for that matter,
forget about quantum mechanics.
So, but we got there,
we got to understanding
that there are atoms and cells,
using the combination of our senses
and our cognitive capacities.
So adding the ability of
our cognitive capacities
to our senses is adding an enormous amount
and I don't think that it
is a hard and fast boundary.
You know if you believe in cells,
if you believe that we
can understand those,
then there's no reason
you believe we can't,
believe in quantum mechanics just as well.